bonsoir à tous ce soir je parlerai au
nom de deux personnes moi même et n'ai
league et qui est l'architecte alors la
polynésie française attire les touristes
pour diverses raisons pour son accueil
traditionnel ces colliers de fleurs à
l'aéroport par sa culture diversifiée
dans différentes dans différents
domaines la danse la cula la danse la
gastronomie le sport la plongée la pêche
elle attire des touristes aussi un
parent par son folklore par son état
d'esprit assez festif
et elles attirent aussi par une
architecture qui est vendu au travers du
monde avec ses bungalows sur l'eau
alors comment faire pour faire venir
plus de touristes en polynésie
sachant que la polynésie aujourd'hui
accueille 180 mille touristes et qu'il
en faudra à peu près 300 milles pour
améliorer l'économie locale
selon les directives du gouvernement et
des différentes études qui ont été
élaborés alors on n'aurait peut-être pas
grand-chose à faire
sachant que nos amis hawaïen ou à peu
près 8 millions de touristes par an que
nos amis aux fidjiens en ont sept cent
mille 11 x 120 mille touristes en plus
c'est pas beaucoup
et donc on pense que l' architecture ap
tête ar ou la jouer là dedans il ya
qu'aujourd'hui elle est allée bien
évolué on a des complexes hôteliers qui
sont assez son dieu
on se dit qu'il faut se tourner vers le
21e siècle et puis peut-être avoir une
vision un peu nobel de l'architecturé
comment faire quand on est architecte
face à cette problématique
eh ben c'est de se dire qu'aujourd'hui
l'architecte doit inventer des choses il
doit innover et doit s'inspirer de la
culture polynésienne des valeurs
traditionnelles et puis inventé inventé
une architecture qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui
alors c'est facile à dire
on n'efface en rien une siens qu'on est
dans le dans un sens de la
mondialisation on est habitué à un
certain confort
aujourd'hui je crois que on s'est trop
inspiré peut-être des architectures
indonésienne au valais balinaise qu'on a
transporté en polynésie et est
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut trouver
cette identité un peu plus dans les
constructions qu'on pourrait réaliser
alors on s'est posé la question en fait
et bien que le bungalow doit garder son
identité
la tique de bungalows sur l'eau avec ses
pieds otis et façades de bois ces
toitures végétales on s'est dit que le
l'emballage que tout le monde connaît on
allait créer un
effet de surprise en fait en
s'imprégnant de ce que de ce que je vous
disais delà de la
valeur traditionnelle et là on est
partis de l'idée par exemple tout
simplement de l'idée du collier de
fleurs tout le mobilier était a été
design et est réalisé dans le même
concept de manière vraiment à être dans
un nuage de fleurs alors pourquoi cette
exubérance parce que les touristes ne
reste pas très longtemps dans ces lieux
et l'idée c'était vraiment de lait de
leurs marques et l'esprit qui repartent
chez eux avec ça dans la tête et qu'ils
puissent en parler et de cette manière
faire de la publicité à la polynésie par
ce biais on pense que la communication
permettraient de faire revenir d'autres
d'autres touristes
voilà échelle encore plus loin et bien
l'architecte se doit dans sa conception
d'hôtel se doit de prendre en
considération
l'environnement d'intégrer au mieux ces
bâtiments on n'a pas le choix on est
obligé de faire avec mais est de tirer
parti de tirer parti des sites sans les
endommager des fois même en les
améliorant
et bien favorise le développement
naturel de la faune parce que ce sont
des endroits qui deviennent protéger des
endroits on n'a pas le droit de pêcher
ce sont uniquement des endroits de
découverte et donc on y voit la faune se
développer
et enfin pour continuer on pense que
le tourisme à l'échelle du territoire a
besoin de lieux
identitaire et je pense que la polynésie
manque de
le bâtiment identitaire fort donc ça
c'était une proposition à l'époque où on
pensait rénover le front de mer et
l'idée était tout simplement de disposer
5 mai gatti qui devant la plage et
simone y donc ils deviennent
l'élément phare de la ville et de la
polynésie parce que et de pascal papé
l'été la porte d'entrée de la polynésie
et de cette manière les paquebots qui
arrivait dans le port ou partie dans le
port été accueillis par des tiki les
avions qui atterrissaient qui décolle
vous pouvez voir cette équipe voilà un
gros gros effort a été réalisé sur la
son réaménagement du front de mer donc
aujourd'hui le front de mer et des mines
est utilisé par tous les polynésiens se
sont accaparés l'endroit et ça
fonctionne vraiment c'est un endroit qui
est utilisé aussi par les touristes
alors cet effort qui a été fait sur le
front de mer eh ben il doit être porté
un peu plus loin il doit aller dans la
ville et la ville doit aujourd'hui c'est
impératif pour le tourisme
la ville doit s'embellir doit avoir
trouvé des os des rues piétonnes trouver
des commerces des restaurants pour
développer l'économie
parce que le tourisme ne vient pas en
polynésie et uniquement pour voir des
lagons bleus il vient aussi encore en
tunisie pour rencontrer des populations
rencontrées une dynamique qui a ici et
voilà on pense que ça travaille
maintenant majeur a pas proposé pour la
ville alors si on peut terminer sur
quelques images
alors on vous a mis ses ces quelques
images là qui sont des éléments des
bâtiments phares de
destination on reconnaît tout un tas de
à droite l'opéra de sydney qui a été
construit en 1977 déjà qui est classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco et qui
est le symbole architectural fort de
dessiner et de l'australie
ensuite plus proche de moi un bâtiment
très moderne très contemporain qui est
le musée guggenheim de bilbao en espagne
ce bâtiment en fait a fait émerger une
ville en espagne toute la ville a été
repensé réaménagement en fonction de ce
bâtiment est aujourd'hui l'économie de
la ville de bilbao a grimpé grâce à ça
et puis enfin au centre le le centre le
musée de tjibaou en nouvelle calédonie
qui est devenu l'élément phare au sida
nouvelle calédonie s'inspirer des de la
culture kanak
et qui permet aujourd'hui de de circuler
au travers de au travers du monde parce
par ce principe voilà on pense que l'
architecture
et pas uniquement du dessin de plans
c'est une réflexion qui pourrait
permettre au tourisme de se développer
d'apporter d'apporter des solutions et
voilà c'est un petit peu la démarche que
nous avons
voilà je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
m